So let me go over a few things with you.
Here are some items to remember.
You need to listen before you transmit and make sure that no one else is speaking.
So before you key that mic, just listen for a moment,...
...make sure no one else is talking at the same time.
Another thing is that you need to always use your call sign when you're using the radio,...
...because if you don't use your call sign, air traffic control is not going to know who's speaking.
And also you want to try to make your transmission as quick as possible.
Think about what you're gonna say first.
Try to make that transmission as quick as possible because while you're transmitting,...
...no other pilot or controller can transmit.
Now, if you want to say "no" on the radio, you don't say "no," you say "negative."
If you want to say "yes," you say "affirmative."
Now, the word "roger," what that means is, it doesn't mean "yes" or "no."
What "roger" means is, "I received your message."
Now, "nine" in German means "no."
So to avoid any confusion, if you want to say the number "nine,"...
...you need to say "niner" while you're on the radio.
And also to avoid confusion because some letters sound similar to one another,...
...let's say there was static on the radio and I said "B,"...
...you might have thought I said "V" and that could cause a problem.
So, instead of saying any letter, you use the phonetic alphabet.
So each letter is assigned a word in the phonetic alphabet.